welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Tisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Mike Ames a bit
about Mike he started in recruitment in
1988 and since then has sold two
businesses and been involved in two
businesses that have sold and the first
one was his very own which sold for 24
million pounds in 1998 and the second
one was a business which she had shares
in and was involved in very heavily at
the start which he then achieved and was
part of the business exit in that
business so two events two moments which
a lot of recruitments and people in
recruitment dream of but when he
achieved that outcome of having a ton of
money no longer working or needing to
work was when Mike was actually in his
darkest moment and we spoke a lot about
that and since then from 2004 he's had
his very own business again called Flair
where there are consultancy they help
smallgram recruitment businesses scale
with more predictability we spoke about
360 models are they the right ones we
spoke about systems and processes that
are going to help all of you that are
running recruitment businesses scale
with more confidence there's so much
value in this conversation I'm really
excited for you to listen to it enjoy
Mike welcome to the podcast well it's
great to be here thank you for inviting
me on looking forward to it yeah so for
those of you uh that don't know Mike I'd
be surprised very consistent in doing
LinkedIn lives sharing content on
LinkedIn which is why I was really
excited to have you on and for me I just
think it's a good place to start by just
giving everyone immediate context on
like where you are on your journey what
you're up to now but most importantly
yeah the journey that you have been on
so
this has been a quite long journey for
you so uh I've got some key sort of
moments some bullets that I think be
relevant for people listening but if I
do miss it kind of thing let me know
yeah
um so got here started an I.T but then
switched to recruitment in 1988
uh set up your own recruitment business
in April 1989 uh
um by 1990 unfortunately your business
partner passed away so then you found
yourself running this business uh by
yourself and movement forward
um you sold your first recruitment
business uh for 24 million to Modis in
1998. you then stayed on for another two
years uh before uh living with around
Circa eight to nine million
um you then was involved with a business
called Crimson from 2001 to 2010 and
helped in a number of different ways
various different ways
um but then left in 2010 and kept your
uh Romanian shares in that business
um you then actually was involved in an
exit and part of the the cell and that
um business at crimson and then now the
journey that you've been on is with
flair which you started in 2004 which is
ultimately focused on micro and small
recruitment businesses and helping them
scale probably worked with over 100
recruitment businesses as a consultant
over that period
um and this is the journey you're on now
building Flair having recruitment
company so probably haven't done that
Justice on trying to condense all those
years into some bullets but they're some
of the key moments
I'm going to be honest with you so yeah
I think I think that's a very good
summation of the last 30 well whatever
35 years 36 years but I think it it's it
has been a journey when you explain it
in that way
I think of all the things that I've
learned and all the mistakes that I've
made which have been like huge numbers
of them so I'm not afraid of failure so
just give it a go and see what comes out
I'll come into the end of that Journey
now it's funny when you describe it I am
coming to the end of it I'm not going to
work forever
and it's all that knowledge I was afraid
would disappear and just disappear into
the ether and that's one of the reasons
that we're recording all these videos
and doing all this work to try and
suck all of this stuff out of me and
stick it somewhere where people can get
access to it all if they want to I mean
they might not want to bother of course
but that's that's the journey that's
where we're at at the moment with the
journey
so basically I normally start with like
the million pound question but I just
wanted to start in a bit of a different
place here because I'm just really Keen
to dig into Mike's perspective Mike's
beliefs around successfully scaling a
recruitment business so I just wanted to
start by like like how would you
describe uh what you do
let's start okay
um what I do is I give people a map of
the maze so everybody's journey is like
a maze it's full of
attractive cul-de-sacs that you think
yeah I'll go down there and you get down
there you realize this is actually a
sack and you've got to come back
and start again having traveled it many
times twice for myself as you quite
rightly pointed out and well over a
hundred for for my clients I kind of got
a map of the maze so what I do is help
people to get to where they want to be
faster and for Less cost and for
considerably less stress
um and I mean we can talk as long as you
like around that but that's essentially
what it is providing people with a map
of the maze a lot less attractive called
the succession those things that seem to
be in the right decisions but they're
not but you only realize that when
you've taken the
yeah and then and then just to add a bit
more context on that uh which is why I
was really also excited to speak to you
is the the business that I'm building we
typically find ourselves speaking to
recruitment owners that are anywhere
between yeah five to 30 40 heads have
aspirations to grow
um and oftentimes find themselves
yo-yoing from maybe 10 to 15 people back
to eight back to nine uh so your sort of
sweet spot is those types of Founders
yeah I know not all of them but that
that tends to be the sweet spot for you
right yeah I think if you were to
describe an ideal client you've got
certain characteristics about the
company which is their size and what
they do I really don't do very much with
High Street pipe businesses it it's not
really something that I work with so
tends to be Professional Services or
more senior hires probably up to search
do quite a lot of search
work and the bottom line is is what
they're looking to do is grow which
isn't difficult just hire some more
people but to grow and keep their shape
so that means
to not lose profitability because when a
business grows a recruitment business in
particular one of the things that tends
to suffer is the percentage
profitability they become what's known
as a scissor company so if you imagine a
scissor that
the top finger there is the turnover
it's going up the bottom finger is the
profit and that's going down so they
want to maintain their profitability
they'll also maintain their service
levels which again often drops as you
grow the clients become dissatisfied
um and also you still want to remain an
employer of choice very often as you
grow you become less attractive for
people working there just it's not the
same as it was you know people say and
of course what happens then you lose
clients you lose stuff it shrinks and
then guess what you do the same thing
all over again in exactly the same way
and get the same results really so what
I do is help people to build a scalable
business based on Seven Pillars seven
components and it works for any service
business it doesn't have to be
recruitment but it works really well in
Recruitment and my background being in
recruitment is very tailored to that but
it's just building a business which is
safe you know that there are three but
three real priorities in a recruitment
business when you're growing it profit
value and safety
so if you've got to have all three so if
you have a profitable business that's
building in value but it's not safe
then something can happen and set you
back say for example the things that
happened to us in 2020
and you can have a business which you
think is worth a lot
um but actually it's profitability
probably means It Isn't So you need
something which is very profitable which
is going to give you value and
ultimately which is safe
and so that's what we do with these
Seven Pillars makes a huge difference if
you focus on that do you think I was
going to ask you actually do you think
that recruiters spend too much time on
some of the more external measurements
like how many staff that they've got the
head count or the turnover a number of
offices that they've got or the number
of countries that they operate in do you
think
people sometimes get sucked into that
little bit
sometimes people can because if you go
down to the pub or you meet up with your
friends and you have your own business
one of the first questions when they go
like how like how's it going like sort
of oftentimes people say oh like how
many people work for you now and these
things right it's typically a lot of the
time what sort of people ask or you're
expected a lot of the time to grow
because you have your own business so
um yeah I I do think sometimes people
can get caught up with that but actually
I think what the actual challenges is
people uh aren't clear on what type of
business they want to build so they find
themselves sort of not clear on do they
want to hire should they be opening more
offices so
yeah
it's interesting you say that well
actually can I just dive in on that
point because that's a really
interesting point right
if you own a business any business
it doesn't matter what it is so your
business my business anyone's business
as the owner you have a core Mission so
you might have a general mission that
you publicize to everybody and we want
to be the best at this that and the
other that's fine
but you've got a cool Mission as the
owner and I think too many owners forget
this they move away from it they don't
really focus on it and that is to give
you the lifestyle that you want which is
a combination of disposable cash and
free time you know you're still having
loads of money but no time and vice
versa is not much good either the second
thing is freedom at work so when you get
to work you're free to do the things you
like
to do the things you're good at and to
do the things that have the biggest
impact and pretty much nothing else what
they call the thousand dollar tasks and
the third thing is to become
independently wealthy to reach a stage
where you can say do you know what
I've had enough I'm I'm out of here
too many people lose sight of that core
Mission and I think if you've specified
those three things written them down put
numbers on them and understand exactly
what it means I think that gives you a
perspective to tell you what you should
grow
because you can even sketch out the size
business that will give you those things
and often it's smaller than people think
it needs to be
if you grow that business and make it
work well you keep that team together
what happens with a team that stays
together so you don't keep adding people
to either losing people
it goes into profit overdrive and I've
seen it countless times in fact the the
show that I did recently with Matt Ellis
you know they treble their profit so
they were big profitable business in the
first place because their team became
stable
in a in a team that's chopping and
changing starters and levers never get
to this stage but you reach this stage
and suddenly your profits double or
treble but your costs are going up it's
amazing when it happens
and that starts with a recognition that
you don't have to keep growing all the
time
you don't have to do that you grow then
you stabilize which means you get your
profitability back up you make sure the
service levels your clients where they
need to be make sure everyone's happy
then if you want to you can grow again
you can it's like a step really
and it's interesting when you look into
this in in the detail of it all really
is that the thing that drives people to
grow is often what you say it's that you
know those recruiters and we all know
they're a Dying Breed now but the Rolex
and loafer Brigade you know that
office in Dubai listen to what an office
in Dubai I don't know but that's about
but and then and then they're they're
not making money or they're not making
vast amounts of money
because they've lost track of it all
it's there to serve you be very clear
what you want the business to do for you
and then construct a business that
delivers it and that will answer most of
the questions or should I do this or
should I do that
just by doing that one thing and it's
it's enlightening when you go through
that process issue
not gonna I can imagine so I do before
we just go into all the sort of your
strategies beliefs I have a ton of
questions on that and I'm sure that's
what people dying to learn from I just
wanted to ask you if I'm honest you
touched on it touched on it earlier
but you just mentioned there around
getting to a point where uh yeah time
Freedom or Financial Freedom like why
why are you doing what you do because
you don't have to be doing this right
now financially right I'm just curious
like that's an interesting story which
which I shall suppress right so
when I was running the first business in
the 90s I was desperate to get to the
stage where the business didn't need me
on a day-to-day basis right desperate to
get to that stage reached it and
realized it was horrible I like to be
involved so that's when we decided to
sell
didn't like working for the Americans
but needed to work
um just for my sanity really and then I
gave up work in 2000 and my business
partner had left as soon as the sale
went through and he just had this great
life he bought this farm he bought this
place in Spain he traveled he bought
these bloody horses and sheep and got
them as well and he just had this great
life and I wanted it until I started to
to live it it was horrendous
my idea I was 40 I suppose that was to
stop working not and retire and never
work again in the end I had to have
counseling I had to have counseling
because I was all messed up in my head
and she said to me
in in your case you you are what you do
so your volume in life is what you do
it's not how much money you earn or how
much money you've got it's the fact that
you do stuff and people recognize it and
you make progress and you like the
journey and she said if I were you I'd
get another job that's what she said to
me so I got another job and I'm never
going to let it go now I'm always going
to work
I'm always going to work I'm always
going to have something that I'm
striving towards be enjoying where I am
at the moment to work with people I like
working with mostly in my family these
days to be honest but nonetheless
um and what I'd like to do is just work
a little bit less I'd like to be on a
three day week but I want to work until
I kill over my dad was 82 when he
stopped working and I told him before he
died I said I'm going to beat that gonna
be 83 so that's an ambition for you
right there in answer to your question
it's part of me it's what makes me me
yeah to have that need to work love it
that's amazing thank you for sharing
that I mean can I can I just I just want
to ask something on this really quickly
and then we'll move on
just because I think I think this is
important like a lot of people that
listen to this podcast have aspirations
of reaching the mountain
um getting to that point that might be I
don't know getting the uh earning 100
Grand it might be exiting a business
right and we put so much weight on
reaching the top of that mountain to
then realize that there's another
mountain right so would you mind just
sharing like I really appreciate you
sharing that you find yourself
um getting help and it enabled you to
realize yeah like you are you are what
you do but like what what did it
actually feel like hurt you know like
talk to us a bit about what did I
actually feel like where you thought you
wanted this life you've had million
pounds and
um uh tons of money in the bank you
thought you wanted this life of living
on a farm not worrying about too much
you know the typical thing that we get
sold yeah I want to retire I want to sit
on a beach drink cocktails all these
things personally that scares the living
hell out of me because I would feel
worthless I'd want to be doing things
but you you experienced that first time
you got there what is it that you
actually felt like how did you actually
feel
when you arrived at that point which you
thought you wanted
it was horrendous you know to just
thinking about it now I'm kind of
reliving it as I'm telling you this I've
started to feel a bit panicky right it
was horrendous was because
I grew up as a with a working class
background right so this all came out in
my therapy I grew up in this
working-class background in the 60s
everybody worked all the men worked a
lot of the women worked because we were
a very working class area right so no
one didn't work it's like whoever works
really so and and by working it means
that I had a Counterpoint when I went on
holiday I really looked forward to my
holidays I really look forward
to a long weekend if we did that or
spending time with with friends abroad
we've got a little place in Wales you
know we can go there really really love
that
when you don't work there's no
Counterpoint every day is a Saturday
every day is a holiday I got to the
stage where it was so desperate if you'd
rang me up and said Mike um
can we can we go for a game of goal from
Tuesday I checked with Doris
I'm I'm having my haircut on Tuesday I
could only do one thing a day because I
like to spread everything out right it
was terrible I watched all the Star Wars
movies about three times and is my wife
in the end that said you know this has
to change this you cannot keep doing
this I was deteriorating big style right
everything that had driven me
the excitement being part of something
the journey
and I had my needs analysis done I don't
know if they've ever had that done but
but people to be happy you've got to
line up your passions with your talents
and your inner needs
passions are easy because they're the
things you think about all the time are
interested in talents are easy because
you just discover you're good at things
you know that but the inner Drive is a
much more complex to work out and they
last forever they were the things that
drove you when you were 5 15 25 105 it
just comes out in different ways so had
these drivers done
and I found that I needed to be on a
journey so I needed to have been
somewhere be somewhere but going
somewhere I need a big risk of failure
with pain attached to it
so just having a risk of failure
with no consequences don't mean anything
to me I need to be in a constant place
of Discovery learning new things well of
course all of that was taken away from
me instantly as soon as I went away from
that that building in Henley Northland
and left it to the Americans to run it
from that point onwards everything that
had made me what I was had been taken
away and you just spiral into a pit of
despair never had as much money in my
entire life honestly but it meant
nothing and as soon as a couple of guys
who worked for me at software knowledge
which was the first business came to me
and said we're going to do this thing
called Crimson would you like to be
involved and my wife said said yes he
can start Monday and that was that
really and I was in and I felt instantly
better even though I couldn't work for
them immediately because of my
restrictive practice Clause I felt
instantly better I've got purpose and I
just felt better I've never lost that
that's one of the reasons I did fly a
really was because I wanted something to
give me those things that purpose and
that place of Discovery in that Journey
it's a weird thing if you haven't done
it if your listeners haven't done it I
would recommend you get the needs
analysis done figure out what really
makes you tick because often it's not
what you think
yeah no thank you so much for sharing
that Mark I really appreciate that I'm
just so fascinated by that just because
I'm sure right like we'll move on here
but like why I'm so interested in that
is because so many people outside
looking into Mike's ames's life would
probably want would would love to switch
places with you right millions in the
bank not having to work and I just find
that fascinating that when you arrived
at that you found it really difficult
and you really yeah like figure out what
it is I've never been um I've never been
suicidal I've never never reached that
stage you know I don't know people that
have reached that stage but you think of
all the famous rich and famous people
that do do end their lives you know it's
not just about the money in the no
they're on fabulous but not about the
five not external things it's the
drivers you have to have your drivers
ticked and we're all different you know
we all got different things and then if
you line that up with things you're
passionate about and interested in and
things that you've got a talent for
you're going to be happy you're going to
be happy and that's the main thing in
life seems to me to be happy
I appreciate that so let's just get
straight into the granular here because
I really like the way that you talk
about things so I've been looking at a
couple of your LinkedIn posts things
that you share things that you talk
about so I wanted to start here because
I think this could be a really valuable
place for people that are listening that
are on that growth Journey
um and find it difficult so well I just
wanted to sort of go to here I'm just
going to share some things with you so
did a post here around the Golden Circle
of growth
so a scalable recruitment business
requires more that more than the Golden
Circle of growth this being win more
clients feel more vacancies make more
money hire more staff some of the common
language that you'll hear people that
are trying to grow their recruitment
business right so this approach that you
shared can oftentimes mean that you
might find yourself at 15 people but
then you drop down to six to eight again
and you find yourself sort of yoyoing
back and forth and I hear this a lot and
this is a lot of the time the types of
recruitment companies that I speak to
with a lot of the UK recruitment
agencies being small to medium size so
what you said in terms of what you need
and this is what I guess I wanted just
to talk to is strong employer value
proposition
a system to win high value new clients a
client care system to make you the
number one supplier a zero cost
marketing engine and a data-based
management framework
let's talk about these why why do we
need these things okay so let's start
with the yoyo thing for a minute why
does that happen well
it happens because you outgrow your
management strength that's essentially
it you know up to about eight people it
starts to the the wheels tend to start
coming off around about eight people and
if they're going to tip off completely
it's before you get to 15. normally it's
that kind of space right
and so you're used to managing by
proximity you're managing because you
sit with everybody you know what the
heck's going on you know it you
everything it's small enough to know
what what everyone's doing where they're
at and it's easy and the management
information that you have the dashboards
tend to be more financial so you know
what you did today is how much money did
you make what you turn over how much
money you've got in the bank and so on
which is important of course but you
don't need anything else because you can
manage by proximity
you get to that magic eight ish number
and suddenly it's more and more
difficult to manage by proximity
particularly if you've got work from
home part of your crew of working from
home it's difficult to know what the
heck's going on so the things that slip
are service levels
so the client is very happy with when
you're a smaller you're in charge of
making sure everyone was everything was
being done as it should be suddenly you
can't do that so some of you people
perhaps aren't as hot on The Client
Services as you are so you start to get
clients that aren't quite as happy
they're perhaps giving work to other
companies and keeping you there maybe in
worst case scenario they throw you out
completely
same goes for staff freely you know it
there's no such thing as a team really
there's just individuals and you should
see them as that when it comes to
management their strengths are weak this
is the things they want to achieve the
things that make them happy the things
that make them sad you get to know them
as individuals
and then you work with them to get the
most out of them I mean that's the
bottom line to focus them where you can
get the most from them well of course
there's too many now there's 10 or 15
people they're not all working in the
office you've lost control of that so
now you're getting people aren't as
happy aren't as motivated as they would
have been and they're not they're not
really delivering in the way that
they've delivered before to his
profitability tends to drop
um and then the final piece of the
jigsaw is that profitability piece and
that means that you're growing too quick
growth is expensive costs it costs money
to grow right
so what often often happens is you grow
but the profits don't keep up with the
money that you're spending and the
turnover that you're bringing in so
that's why your profit degrades
so if you don't change your money to
instructure the way in which you direct
to control your business you'll outgrow
it and then it's look at the drawer if
you're successful look at the drawers
you get through that and I think that's
a pretty poor way of running a business
quite frankly I think you need to
organize a business in a way
that
that scalability is not affected doesn't
affect your profitability your service
level through your staff motivation
we've got a saying you can't make a
butterfly by making a caterpillar bigger
it just can't just get a really fat
caterpillar what you have to do is
reform it in the Chrysalis and then it
can come out as a beautiful butterfly
and it can fly away and it's like that
with a business really you have to
reform at certain times and about eight
to ten people is the first one
20s late 20s is the second one and then
around about 50 or 60s the third one and
probably after that but I never got that
before I've got to try to Lisa I'd sold
the business by that stage but
but I think this recognition that your
business needs to change its shape in
order to keep your profitability your
service levels
um and your style of satisfaction and
motivation levels is alien to most
people because they're just locked into
that Golden Circle we'll just hire some
more people I'll get some more people
and we get some more vacancies and then
and then we'll make some more money and
it's like really really is that really
because that's not gonna fly well if you
if you don't if you don't get a handle
on that then you'll have a pretty
miserable life putting out fires all the
time that's what it turns into it's
horrible
you know it's not a good thing at all so
so the reason for that particular post
was just to bring people this attention
and actually know
you kind of need more you know it's
that's that's one of the Seven Pillars
right you've got seven pillars one of
them is fulfillment which is that really
it's about getting more vacancies making
more placements okay
whereas if you think of the assets so
the structure that your business is made
up of the first one is Direction and
control which is
a recognition of what the business has
got to do for you as the owner your cool
cool mission that we talked about
earlier
the dashboards that you need in order to
know what the heck is going on in your
business as it grows
and then what you do with that data the
meetings that you have the changes that
you make and the plan that you're
running to move the business from where
you are to where you want it to be
then you have your fulfillment I'm not a
big 360 guy
it's a nightmare really I think makes
life 10 times more difficult you know
much more of a layered approach to be to
to fulfillment
then you have your marketing machine
which supports getting new staff in get
new head counted
um getting new clients and looking after
existing clients and then at the end of
it is just that support services that
you can just Outsource most of them to
be honest but they have to be done and
you need all of them
to reflect not the size business you
owned out
but the next iteration of the business
that you want in other words if you
don't change in advance
of the need you're always running hot
the thing is always under strain it's
never comfortable so if you're gonna
have a growth spurt put things in place
that you can grow into you know like
when you're at school we were very poor
so Mom used to buy me enormous trousers
right in in September and
um it was sorry about that it was um
by the time they fitted me by the time
January February time came
and then I reached sort of
by May June time and they were really
tight and then the process started again
well you're you're creating a business
so she's got big trousers you know so
you can grow into them and then don't
get us don't wait until the treasures
are tight again grow another big pair
you know what I mean I'm not explaining
that terribly well but it's about
creating a business ready to grow into I
think that's probably well that makes
that's that makes that makes complete
sense so I'm gonna I'm gonna
I wanted to uh that was one of my
questions around the 360 in the factory
model so I'm going to ask you about that
but just to get a bit more granular here
thank you for breaking that down I'm not
I'm a big advocate for that for my own
business I mean there's
um there's only three of us but my
mentality has been I want us to be eight
or nine by the end of the year and I've
sort of really committed to having
processes and a bunch of different
things that I think I'm going to thank
myself for in another 12 months time and
I think yeah you'll completely right a
lot of recruit known as I speak to are
just unproductive chaos uh and there's
just like like I said just strain
fighting fires
um I'll worry about that when we have a
couple more people in the business and I
will whenever I sit down with people
it's like one of the best things that
you can do is build those processes and
do things today that you are going to
thank yourself for instance 12 months
time and you've got to think about yeah
um act as if you are a business of 10
people before you're already there so
can we just take a moment then to think
about if I'm listening to this right now
I am that chaotic business business
where we're getting some good amount of
jobs in we've got people in the business
probably 360 a bunch of 360 recruiters
um yeah I am not thinking about uh I'm
more thinking about yeah let's just get
more jobs on them hire more people uh
but if I am going to listen to your
advice and take your advice on right
actually I do need to make decisions
today whilst I'm in this position to
make it easier as we do grow like you
said have build bigger trousers to to
grow into right what is like the first
step because a lot it's overwhelming
where the hell do I start I've got all
these different things you just
mentioned like how many different things
a marketing engine a lot all these
things what is the first step like what
is the first thing you would advise me
to do that can be the domino effect I
can answer that there's two things
actually one after the other and you
have to you have to do them both really
um so the first thing is going back to
that cool Mission you should be very
clear
what that business has got to do for you
and too many people aren't they've just
got some sort of vague idea that they'd
like to retire when they're 50.
I don't think that's good enough at all
right so you really need to understand
and document and discuss with your
family because it affects them as well
to discuss with them what exactly it is
this business that you own that it's a
slave for you not the other way around
at least it's not supposed to be what is
that business going to do for you define
that core Mission that's a big step
forward because now you've got clarity
on exactly what the business has got to
do for you it's going to give you
Clarity on the size that you need it to
be you don't have to restrict it to that
size you can make it as big as you like
but you've got Clarity over that because
then you can begin the next thing you
can do is shape a business you can
sketch it out numbers of people really
kind of what profitability you would
like to do where you would like to work
none of this costs any money to do this
you can just do it in the evenings or at
weekends it's not even time intensive
really it's just dreaming I suppose but
it's dreaming based upon what the
business has got to do for you and
that's a different kind of dream right
but and that's well and good you can
anyone can do that you could do that now
if you wanted to for your business right
it's not difficult but what you really
have to do
then is begin to look inwards and begin
to look at the business that you have
now there's an old-fashioned device that
we all know they're called a SWOT
analysis strengths weaknesses
opportunities and threats
well
um the first thing to do is to do a SWOT
analysis of the business and get
everybody in the business to do their
own version of it bring it all together
and you have everything on a piece of
paper that tells you what's great about
your business the strengths that you
need to leverage make more use of and do
things with the weaknesses where
problems in your business the things
that you need to fix and sort out
opportunities which are effectively
things that you could make more of in
the future I don't tend to go excited
about those while I've got weaknesses
and and threats on the board and then
you've got threats which are just
problems in Waiting they're not a
problem now but they could well be in
the future
and so your first step is to is to take
that information and begin to think
about what it means it changes fixes
really so we're not doing anything
strategic now I'll do any of that we're
just looking at some fixes and those
fixes are going to are going to drop in
those seven different pillars
are guaranteed they'll be that you've
lost control so you need to put some
control back in the Fulfillment isn't
efficient you know you when you put your
metrics and you realize that you're not
really you're
um ratio between profit and payroll
which is a good ratio to measure by the
way is too low and it's not going in the
right direction you know your payroll is
going up but your profit isn't going to
put the same rate
um so you need to do something around
fulfillment marketing is a service to
the other three pillars so wouldn't
worry about marketing just yet but are
you do you suffer from high staff rates
of you know attrition rates
if you do an analysis if you ask they
call it the vote don't they voice of the
employee if you do an anonymous vote
what will they say about working here
you know it's good good thing to do that
do you need to do something about
plugging the gap of people good people
leaving and trying to get new people in
do you have enough high value new
clients because as we've talked about
you and I before the show
there's two types of Business
Development and there's tactical
Business Development which is basically
give us a give us a vacancy or I've got
this great candidate which is what most
of the industry does if you don't build
Empires on that you build an Empire on
strategic Business Development where
you're chasing a relationship with a
high value client could take months or
even years to get in there but when you
get in there the money flows so what
how's your business development function
working and of course with client care
are you maximizing the value are you the
Apex supplier for at least 20 of your
clients in other words are you their
first choice well your SWOT analysis
will bring all of this in it's not that
difficult and you can begin to
tactically plan how you're going to sort
out these weaknesses because that's the
first thing really think about the
threats are any of them imminent or
catastrophic because if they are you
need to mitigate them then you can move
on to your opportunities and your
strengths should we make more of our
threats and can we capitalize on these
opportunities rocket science at all it's
incredibly simple actually
having done that
I think the next stage does that make
sense by the way am I is that yeah yeah
I think no that does that's like really
helpful because I think oftentimes when
I do speak to uh people there all they
see directly in front of them are like
the the problems of that week or the
problems of that month and
um I think if people are being honest
when do they last take a step back to
really realign or have Clarity on what
they want personally and then also yeah
actually look in the mirror and go right
what are we really good at uh what are
we not so good at well that that's an
interesting thing because a lot of
people all of us human beings to assert
to greater or lesser extent driven by
ego you know what we think about
ourselves and what we wanted the people
to think about us and if we admit that
we've got something wrong we have a
weakness that can be construed by some
people as an attack on themselves and
nobody likes that so much better to deny
we've got a problem
much better to desire that there are no
weaknesses because then we don't have to
worry about it we're cool we're great
and I think it's so much easier to put
your ego in the box and go with the data
you know what they say facts don't care
about feelings and if you've got a
problem you've got a problem you know
you might as well admit it and deal with
it rather than we'll hope it goes away
or pretend it's not there I did a um the
show today to Thursday we're recording
this uh we did a show on leadership
mentality because massively different
from recruiter mentality and you get a
lot of people who run businesses quite
big businesses sometimes who are
basically still just recruiters even if
they're not doing recruitment on a
day-to-day basis their mentality is
recruitment
on one of those things in in one of
those seven characteristics of a of a
scalability mentality and Leadership
mentality is this ability to not feel
guilty
when you're not on the tools when you're
not working in your business you're
working on your business so you're
building a strategy you're building
plans you're executing the plans you're
going out and listening you're listening
to your show right so you can you've got
some interesting guests coming on
sharing what binder you're feeding
yourself with new ideas shouldn't feel
guilty about that in the same way that
you shouldn't feel guilty about taking
holidays they're necessary business
Investments
and if all you do is work in your
business that's all you'll ever do the
more you work on your business today
they'll actually work in your business
tomorrow
and if you want to scale you've got to
put some time time forward it'll always
say if you're a small business and
you're not doing anything a day a
quarter which is a strategy day so no
funds no no emails just a strategy day
to think about the strategy and plan
and then and then you need an execution
tied so what about having a plan but if
you don't execute it there's not a lot
of Point having the plans so then you
need to put aside some time each week to
execute one of my clients has just
finished with me so it's been with me
for 18 months
he began to execute on the Saturday
morning that was his time before the
kids got up two or three hours on a
Saturday morning
that made enough time then for him to be
able to execute in the week
so he was not just working in the
business in the week he got to the stage
where he was doing a four day working in
the business and a one day working on
the business and of course as soon as
you do that
your potential accelerates you know it
just massively accelerates because
you're actually making changes to the
business there and the people who are in
it and I I think the more that you
realize that working on the business for
a leader
is more important than working in the
business as the business gets bigger
the sooner that you make that transition
to a scalable business
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincere and saucebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you're able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're a growing recruitment business
you have to check out Vin Cherry who are
an all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with
saucebreaker if you want to make sure
that all of your recruiters have the
best tools on the market to stand out
and beat their competition then you have
to check out Source breaker use the link
in the show notes in the comments below
and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products
so just to
continue this for a second again just to
give people some more tangible advice so
what I'd love you just to talk through
maybe you could describe it or talk
about the fundamental differences if I
was a business owner of a 20 personal
recruitment business that has invested
in
processes infrastructure that has
enabled me to grow to that right rather
than trying to get to that point with
the mentality of getting more jobs
hiring new people
like what how how different would that
business look compared to a business of
around eight to ten people
what are what some of the things if
you'd actually made the transition yeah
so I guess what what I'm Keen for you to
share is maybe I don't need to add that
context the main context is what
like to have like a successful
profitable recruitment business with 20
at um 20 people what are the how
fundamentally different will that look
the makeup of it the infrastructure how
different would that look compared to a
business of eight people which as you
said is probably the Tipping Point
the biggest difference will be in that
in the first pillar which is Direction
and control
because every time you grow to the next
stage you need to revisit how you're
managing the thing because it's bigger
it's more of its right so that company
would have dashboards which told the
leadership team exactly what was
happening in the business and I don't
just mean all conversion rates for for
vacancies or debtor days or any of that
sort of stuff I mean in terms of say new
business development you've got the
pillar right so it would tell you how
many people you've got in your
relationship pipeline how many people
you have in the revenue pipeline you'd
understand the rate that those have been
developed called sales flow but it's the
speed that those relationships are
getting closer and closer to becoming
clients all of this data if you set it
up properly on the ethereum system can
tell you what the heck is going on and
if you're not putting enough effort into
that for example
then at some point in the future you're
not going to have the work that you need
you'll have run out of work for the
sustainability of the business that you
have so these dashboards will tell you
what's happening in different parts of
the business that would be one
difference
a really big difference is so the first
level of scalability is when you break
break the link between how much you work
and how much you earn so your one-man
band or solopreneur
and if you don't work you don't earn
money then you hire some people to get
some people in now you can take a bit of
time off and they're doing the work so
you break broken that link between how
much you earn and how much you work
the next level of scalability is that
there's no one person
in your organization in any part of the
organization where the success of the
things that that person does depends
upon them in other words you've
massively reduced key person dependence
so you think for small business
say the owner is the person that brings
in the new business well they've got
that really good 360 that brings in
these clients if they weren't there that
function would fail
in scalable businesses there's a
tremendous amount of or less dependency
on people I mean obviously if someone
leaves it's going to be an impact but it
is there's less of an impact if someone
leaves because you've replaced
individuals
who are the system effectively they are
the person that brings in the new
business they are the person that looks
after the staff and you've replaced it
with a system that people work in so if
they go we'll just get someone else to
work in that system and I'll be very
clear what I mean by system as well just
just clarify this processes are
important of course they are but most
people don't file processes so
to be honest they're only if they're
they're of good they're a good use a
good way to communicate best practice so
they're good for that right 100 the
biggest impact on a business is tools
and I don't mean software tools by the
way
because what a tool will do
is simplify
is standardize and speed up and it
doesn't matter whether that's a tool in
the office or a tool in the kitchen or a
tool in the workshop that's what tools
do so if you tool up what you're doing
is de-skilling
because the whole point of what we're
trying to achieve here is we're trying
to achieve outstanding results with
average people because the majority of
people you employ will be average
obviously that's what average means and
the way what are the ways that you can
do that is tools to de-skill to speed up
you know to standardize so you get that
great that great consistency of output
well a company of around about 20 to 30
will have invested in tools some
software to be fair but other tools as
well that are doing this for them so now
there's a less dependency on individuals
and their individual skills and their
knowledge and their experience and their
Network for Success it's the fact that
they become an operator of a machine
really in a sense
give me an example of a tool in in the
business and the Fulfillment business
it's been the rest of our time talking
about tools but I'll just pick one which
is easy development right because I know
people talk about business development
right so I don't believe in cold calling
I I just think you know it's tactical
business development that it's very
worst it's horrendous really
um and it's such a waste of time and
effort and blah blah blah right so
supposing then
supposing we
worked out a series of interactions that
we could focus on the target market
and they're all pre-written and
pre-tested and we just have to run it
like a big computer program lately in
real life though
and so I'll give you an example I'll
make it real right supposing we sent a
postcard through the post traditional
picture postcard handwritten on the back
that said I'm going to send you a little
package in a couple of days just look
out for that grams their attention
begins to build a bit of Interest okay a
couple of days later there's a package
comes and in the package is a nice
little box of chocolates and a letter
that says look you know in the position
that you're in do any of these problems
um or any of these issues that you've
had with agencies do they resonate with
you
um the reason I've said the chocolates
give you something to nibble on while
you're just reading through this
if if they are I'm going to email
something to you which I think you're
going to be interested in it's an e-book
a couple of days later the ebook comes
through on an email and at the same time
we invite them to connect on LinkedIn
which is a sort of a test and in the
ebook it describes exactly what people
can do to to get around these issues or
the way in which they can manage
whatever it is that the problem relates
to in order to do initial problem we'll
make it go away
and then and that's on an email and then
following that as an invitation connect
on LinkedIn and then there's a final
email which is just a video that says
look either
got a list of don't know what's
interesting I'm just going to give you a
call if you don't want me to give you a
call please just say so and I won't but
I'm going to give you all next week I'm
not looking for a vacancy I just want to
establish whether your values and my
values are the same and my flavor of
recruitment is tasty for you good
you can develop that that's Loosely
based on one of the campaigns called an
ADA campaign we can develop that and
make it work and you keep testing it and
testing each of the individual pots
until it works all the way through and
it gives you what they call a one to X
conversion rate so one conversation to X
number of campaign people that you put
through the campaign that's a tool so we
use that we don't use it at the moment
because most of our leads are inbound
but we did used to use it and what PA
used to run it I developed it and
designed it and she used to run it
massively de-skilled it I ring in at the
end and they're waiting for the call
sometimes they ring you bizarrely enough
if you do a good enough job that's a
tool it's it's it speeds up the process
it's a seven day process from beginning
to end right the end of it that the
beginning that over you are at the end
of it that they're speaking to you on
the telephone massively simplified the
whole process pretty much anyone can
write that call and it's standardized it
so there's a standard set of messages
which are going out to the clients you
see how that works that's just one
example there's loads of these that you
can do tons of them recruitment is
riddled with opportunities for tools and
I don't just means software problem with
software of course is anyone can buy it
so it's not much of a differentiator
really but these kind of tools you can
really differentiate them very powerful
stuff
yeah they're probably it's really
interesting what you're saying because
I'd probably the terminology that I'd
probably used to describe that obviously
I know because we're talking
specifically around BD but you can take
the same framework and principles to
other parts of your business
the article that almost like an
engagement strategy like what what is
our what is our process I now keep using
the word process but what is our tool
what is our system that we follow that
turns Mike our sort of idle customer a
company or a hiring manager that we
assume has a lot of the challenges and
problems that we know that we can
probably help until we actually speak to
them we can clarify that but we thought
about who can we help most and we've got
sort of a track record of helping these
types of people
and what do I do to turn that person
into someone that interacts with me or
knows how I can help them
um and there's an opportunity to connect
and start building a relationship with
them because this is something yeah I
spoke to a lot of recruitments about
this where I said to them like if you're
being honest with me if you were to
round up uh 20 of your recruiters and
and ask them to explain to you and talk
through how they turn people who are in
their target market that don't know
about them into people that are booking
in meetings with them do you think
they'd be able to sort of describe and
articulate how they do that
and obviously more often not the answers
no to that no and this is what we're
talking about here right like it did and
the thing is what I found I don't know
if you found this I speak to one of my
friends about this who's in recruitment
is what's really funny is there are
probably tools that people are using in
your business right now that you're not
even aware of or the entire team aren't
aware of and what's really missed is
this intentional sharing of what's
working and one of the best things that
you can do is round your team up
together and go hey guys
what's working what are you find in
working right now like what are you
finding the the hiring managers we're
trying to speak to
um buy a lot on like what are the
problems that you're finding really
resonate with people and a lot of this
information and tools and knowledge is
often actually in your organization and
a couple of people might be doing it but
they just there then there's no
intentions
it's called positive deviance so if
you're a name for it and it's sent back
to the Vietnam War I won't tell you the
story but it's a good story actually but
we just don't have the time but it
basically sometimes when we have a team
of people we look at the underperformers
we look at the people that aren't eating
targets we Zone in on those guys but
clearly we do because you know we want
to lift their performance
but what we often do is we ignore the
over performers
we ignore those people who are doing
something different
but that difference is delivering much
better results positive deviants is what
they are and those cats if you look at
those guys right
some of those things that they do only
they can do because of their particular
experiential skills or whatever fine
many of them anyone could do it's just
that they do them and nobody else does
and the best way to find positive
deviance is to start with the numbers
because if somebody's doing something
different and they're doing it well
that's going to show up in the figure
somewhere it'll just show up because
there's a consistency to it and that's
your starting point the other thing that
you can do is you can talk to people on
a one-to-one basis and you can go
through exactly how they do things talk
me through how you do it now it's better
to do that on a one-to-one basis because
some people don't like to talk in a
group they feel awkward or a little
exposed or people can make fun of them
if they say something but if you do it
on a one-to-one basis you suddenly
realize that they're doing this and no
one else is doing that that's pretty
cool why do you do that that no I've
always done it really if I do that I'll
get this ah wow and these positive
deviants kind of people in your business
and you all have them pretty much
everybody he does
you can unlock so many ideas and and
efficiencies from that and bring that
into your business for zero cost because
in many cases it doesn't cost them to do
the thing that they're doing in the way
that they're doing it they just do it
that way
and I think it's brilliant to me you've
got a very good point there
yeah now look I know look we're gonna
overrun a bit here because there's a
couple more things I really want to make
sure we speak about if that's okay with
you well normally we sort of run the
hour mark but let's just go over
slightly if that's the right review
um I wanted to make sure that I asked
you here like I'm again because we're
thinking of the types of people that you
speak to a lot uh speak a lot to
um this recruitment business that are
trying to grow
like yeah I've heard you I saw I watched
one of your videos around like the
debate around the 360 versus factory
model
so I want to make sure that we speak
about this because so my perspective on
it I heard you say a lot of 360 is
entirely flawed so I want to hear like
why that is and why you believe that is
the case okay but just quickly just let
me add my context really quickly so I
don't know what your perspective is
right now
um but for a lot of um recruitment
companies that I'm seeing or speaking to
a lot of them want more of their teams
to be more self-sufficient at winning
new business
um and a lot of uh people in their
organization aren't capable of doing
that and they need more of their people
to do that and like you said they're
they're feeling vulnerable there's only
one or two people capable of it uh and
uh that's something that's really
important to a lot of companies that I
speak to that they want more of their
people to have the ability to win their
business now the thing that I'm seeing
is a lot of the redundancies
um and people not losing their jobs or
companies sort of shrinking a lot of the
time from what I can see it's a lot of
these businesses that did go down the
talent partner RPI model or really sort
of grew too quickly like you've just
said is probably part of it where they
had these people in their business on
really high Basics 50 Grand 60 Grand 70
grand because these recruiters are
really high in demand over the last two
years
um but then when all of a sudden
um projects get pulled companies have
said they needed to hire 800 people next
year are now only hiring 20 people and
you've got these uh people that don't
want to do business development aren't
capable of doing it and are on really
high Basics uh are being made redundant
and they then want more of their people
to be able to win
um new business so I don't know I just
feel like I'd love to just hit your take
because I do feel like hooray growing
recruitment yeah we can do that it's
really important okay so
um well there's a lot to unpack there
and I'm going to do real quick because
I'm conscious of the time
first thing to say is as I was saying to
you earlier my
deepest firmest belief the root belief
of everything I do is you've got to
build a business that delivers
exceptional results with average people
because statistically if you look at a
distribution curve most people are
average right so if you're holding up
for those top 10 where you're competing
with Michael page and all these others
with the big money so I'm not sure I
will go down that route
as soon as you accept that
then clearly things like tools that we
talked about earlier come into play
because they de-skilled things processes
because they standardize things
dashboards because they tell you what
the hell's going on right so you're
already going down a route which means
well
hell you know we don't we don't need
somebody to do everything
like Henry Ford who used to have people
build entire cars if someone left he
couldn't finish the car no we just need
someone to put a wheel on because
because we can make him real good at
that we can make them real good so they
put that wheel on real quick and if they
leave we'll just get someone else and
try and put a wheel on no big deal
and it's the same really I think people
haven't caught up to it because they
think that 360s is an easy way to grow
you just imagine yourself at the front
of the office a whole bunch of three
sixes and you're kind of surveying this
group of people that don't need you or
anything really they're just they're
just knocking it out the park
well you know that doesn't really happen
very often does it you know and and if
you get somebody who's a really good 360
if you're looking over the office and
you're looking at them right now as you
listen to this you're probably looking
at a future competition right there
right there because if they can do
everything why do they need you
why do they need you if they can do
everything I believe you should build
dependencies into your people sounds
terrible doesn't it but I think you
should make people dependent upon the
business for it for their success have
you ever heard of anyone taking like a
real top biller from a real big company
say like Michael page or whoever
bringing them into their smaller
business and they don't deliver
the reason that they delivered or part
of the reason they delivered when they
were in a big organization is they were
just part of a bigger system
where they spend a lot of money on
marketing they've got all these computer
systems in place they've got support
people doing this that and the other
they've got all this stuff and this
person who believes it's all down to
them because they're fabulous and
they're 360 they're not really 360 at
all they're not they think they are
because they're told they are but
they're not
the business itself is providing a lot
of the stuff that they need take them
out of that environment put them into a
smaller environment and they can't do a
lot of the things they did before
because the support isn't there so the
idea is to build in those dependencies
make people just do one part of it
because if you think of a 360 just how
many skills are you going to need
to be a successful I mean how many
masteries do you need I think that's
really hard I don't think average people
can do that
right I don't think that at all really
can you get someone who can find really
good candidates yeah sure yeah you can
do that that's not a problem can you get
someone who can make a placement yeah my
age you don't can make a place for now
what could that be forgot about Canada
the
can I find somebody can manage a client
client to make that client feel special
that's harder but yeah we can do that
that's not difficult and then you're
just left with this new business thing
no no it's a really important point on
this
is that most recruiters view Business
Development as what we would call
tactical BD here's a job
gives a vacancy or I got this great
candidate I'll come a speculate right
that's okay but that's very
transactional and if that stops
immediately you run out of work
I'd like everyone listening to this to
this podcast there to think of their
best clients the client that gives them
the most money profit right not
necessarily the one that they get the
most placements with because they might
be really crappy deals but the one that
makes the most money supposing you had
two more of those every year coming into
your business just two one if you like
but just and you knew they were going to
come in how would that change the world
well over time what it would mean you
would need to do less and less tactical
Business Development because these
companies would come in and start to
unleash feed vacancies into your
business
that's what strategic Business
Development does it's completely
different to Tactical BD you only need
an average business so either my
business was about 40 million quid I
suppose when I sold it 70 million
today's money I guess and we had three
strategic business developers that fed
that entire business
possibly four three and a half I'll go
with right
you don't need a lot you don't need
everybody to do strategic BD you just
need one person in the small business to
do it and twice a year you get a drop of
a new client more if you're effective at
what you do now you compare that to what
we have now
in in a bull market in an active Market
anybody can do tactical Business
Development it's easy
because there's a shortage of people so
if you ring in and say got a great
candidate you can make a placement well
Hearing in a second I'm a vacancy and
they've struggled with their existing
agencies for months and I've got the
right person yeah okay give you a crack
that but if the market tightens then
they don't need to do that so that
business development don't work anymore
strategic Business Development works all
the time because what you're doing is
building a relationship you're building
a relationship which we both recognize
is actually a Business Partnership that
doesn't work with everybody because some
people don't want that some clients just
want the best deal they can get and
that's fine and if you want those as
clients good luck to you I want clients
that are going to Value me and have a
steady stream of work coming in that I
can rely upon and I want more and more
and more of them
it's a completely different way of
building a business to begin with unique
tactical then you need tactical and
strategic if you do it properly you just
have strategic in the end and people are
doing a little bit of specking if they
can in that kind of stuff right and and
that's why I don't like 360s because
they're expected to do something which
the market isn't particularly conducive
towards now I mean it's not bad it's not
a bad Market but it's not as good as it
has been in the past and if it gets
worse tactical Business Development just
won't work then what you're going to do
how's that going to work then what these
these people can actually find
candidates and they could place them but
no one's giving them the vacancies it's
the businesses in my mind it's the
businesses the company itself it's their
responsibility to set up a business that
set up a functional system that brings
in these vacancies from these high value
clients then you can just go and do what
you need to do and you can't go anywhere
else because you can't bring business in
so you stay here but we're building
those dependencies in the business 360
is exactly the opposite we're going to
make you independent but we're going to
still going to take 60 of the revenues
that you earn right well no that doesn't
no no no I do all of this myself
I don't need anything to set up a
recruitment company in my back bedroom
hell most of the people listen to this
podcast that own a business did that I
did it twice right
we started a business on the back of
someone else well as you're listening to
this somebody's having this idea I'm a
great 360. I can bring clients in I can
get vacancies I can find candidates I
can place them why do I need to give 60
of more revenues to these guys I'll just
go and keep 100 that's what we think I
mean the truth is a bit different to
that and that's really why I don't like
360s they're hard to find they're hard
to trade they're hard to keep and if
they do go they're going to take a
revenue stream with you much better and
you need really good ones right really
good ones to make it work much better to
build a business that doesn't need them
because it's safer for a start profit
value and safety safer if they do go
they can't take all your tools and
processes and support systems with them
all right good luck to you mate because
that's not gonna fly and you can build
in this safety mechanism into your
business that means you grow steadily
and predictably because you can always
get these average people there's loads
of them around you're not paying the
Earth for that right it's the system
that has the value not the people and
that would be my advice if I were you
pure whether you're a 10 12 112
company person is to build those
dependencies and get away from 360s as
soon as you can or at least minimize the
amount of 360s you've got in your
business
so can we just then like I just want to
go a bit grinding here because I know
people will be thinking of this so I've
heard you say when you talk about the
factory model it isn't just about the
Fulfillment the 180 the 360 whatever
which I do think a lot of people think
right when you talk when they are you
talking about here this they're going
okay Mike well what what recruits do I
hire them what do they do because I know
you're talking about the entire
organization and having depend um yeah
the uh are you having dependencies on
the company for marketing to perform and
uh the different parts of the business
so come and just focus on fulfillment
for a second because that that is that
is what a lot of people think about and
and that is what's most important to
them so can you just explain to us if we
don't have so if I'm a team of um 15
people and right now
um 10 of those are 360 recruiters
they're building their own patch
um and let's be honest I do completely
agree with what you're saying and I
think it goes in line with what a lot of
people say which is it's like running
your own business within the business
right and the story is exactly the same
each time but I think a lot of people
are entirely unaware on what what is the
other option because from what I speak
to people it's like that option or we
have people that just do the candidate
side we have people that just do the BD
side and they're my two options so what
what does this what does this actually
look like like what are the job titles
what are their responsibilities can we
just talk about that for a sec before
what I need you to do is first of all
think of functions
and then think of roles so separately so
let's talk about recruitment functions
we need finders that can find candidates
we need qualifiers that can make sure
they're the right candidates for the job
we need places that can take a short
list and present it to the client and
negotiate them
that arrange the interviews and all that
sort of stuff that sits on top of that
we need carers look after clients to
make sure that the clients come to us
first and keep the competition out and
we max out the revenues from that
um we need Hunters who are going to get
new clients and possibly getting
tactical business developments as well
and we need leaders someone that can
control the whole thing and hold it
together they're not roles they're
functions so when you start off in
one-man band a sonopreneur I should say
you do all of them you do all of those
fortunes you've got all of those hats we
usually use hats when we're demonstrated
this goal there's actually to do them
all then you hire an offshore resourcer
well okay that's the finder someone else
is doing the finding now I'm still doing
everything else but I'm doing the find
it and so what you can do is you can
build up your job titles the roles
whatever
based upon those different functions and
you can decide to cut it how you like
personally my own personal view having
done this several times
various different size companies is the
first thing you say to people is look
here's the deal
um we're going to run a factory model
now and within that factory we're going
to have a layered fulfillment
model you choose you can stay 360 and
that's fine well you can become layered
so you're going to be in a layered
you're going to be doing something in
this layer one or two of these functions
I know it's going to cut
right the chances are you'll have an
easier life
and I'm less stressed and you'll make
more money to get on the layered route
but you won't think you will because
you'll think oh yeah well I'm giving up
some commission well fine right okay
we'll carry on the way you are then but
what we find is the people that move
into layered are doing the things they
like they're doing the things they're
good at they're doing the things that
that have the biggest impact on the
business for them and they make more
money I don't know whether you've
watched the video that we did of um
recently of uh Matt Ellis from
engines went from 300 to 600 000 pounds
billing using this layered model so
we're talking an order of magnitude here
right we're talking a big number and if
somebody gets wrapped up on that we'll
find status of 360. I don't mind do what
you want to do and he did that he said
to people what do you want to do and
some people stayed 360s awesome you know
they benefit anyway because the factory
has got a marketing function and they'll
benefit from that they don't pay for it
so that's cool but actually it's the
layered people they've got they've got a
career path they've got they go to work
and they do what they're good at they
don't they really enjoy and because I
typically chopped up then because I
thought I know what people think how
have you seen that typically be chopped
up in terms of like do you know what I
mean if we're thinking of people and the
layers like out of all those layers you
know I mean how is it typically chopped
up do you have one person typically
being a hunter do you have typically
have one okay okay so we've got the
functions now what we're talking about
is the rolls right yeah that that varies
from company to company because
basically if you're starting from
scratch it's easy you're the owner you
do everything yeah first person you
bring in are the finders then the
qualifiers and then you have a
consultant that does placing and con and
there's such a root there's a path so I
don't have the time to go through it's
pretty straightforward we can't do that
with the existing company because you've
got company so you have that
conversation do you want in the layer or
do you want to stay 360 you know this is
how it works these are the finances this
is so you used to get 100 to the of the
GP going into your commission probably
doesn't work on that because you're
Outsourcing some of the work that you
don't like or you're not good at just
somebody else in the business you go pay
for that
but the fact that you're left doing the
things that you're good at you know so
so typically in a typical small business
you're going to have Consultants
and what they'll probably do they'll do
placements for sure and they'll probably
do qualification that somebody else will
do the finding probably offshore is
would be my advice to you get a good
offshore person and and send it out you
don't have to you can do it unsure if
you want so you've got Consultants to do
in placing some of them perhaps do some
client care you let them lose all
clients some of them you don't you just
give them vacancies right and they just
work on it
um and then you have a pod leader it's
all organizing pods a pod leader manages
the Pod manages the team
um probably does strategic Business
Development so they're the person that's
actually building these relationship
over the months and years to bring in
the bigger higher value clients they
probably do that they may do a little
tactical they may not depend on the size
of the team some of the Consultants may
do some tactical BD you know gives a job
we've got this great candidates all you
might Outsource some of that to the
marketing department so I know it's not
a very good answer but every single
every single one I've done has been
different I mean they're never the same
because they're people but essentially
you take what you've got
you take on board the people that want
to get in the layered routes you figure
out what they're good at and you assign
them then to that particular role you
give them the functions that they're
good at and they want to do and then you
fill the gaps with new people it's not
it really isn't that difficult I've made
it sound a lot more difficult than it is
issue it's not that hard at all
no no I appreciate Shannon because I
know that's what people will be thinking
right now the question I get asked all
the time how can I convert to 360 to lay
it and over a period of time is my
answer but
um but it doesn't happen overnight and
you most people end up with a blended
fulfillment function so it's you know
like a 20 percent
360s they don't hire anymore but the
ones they've got are okay so I'm leaving
B and then they builds up from 20 34 to
50 60 70 percent
layered
cool so let's come to the end here I
appreciate sharing all those insights
and I know we've gone really granular
and a few different things here but I do
really believe that people listening
particularly on the entrepreneurial
Journey will find the things that we've
spoken about most uh interesting so I'll
just I just wanted to sort of end I
guess on asking you just a really simple
question uh which is look you find
yourself working with so many different
recruitment organizations who are on
this journey uh what what is like the
most common bit of advice that you find
yourself giving time and time again
because it's probably around the same
challenge that you hear time and time
again I don't know if there's anything
specific that you find yourself going
this is the fifth time I'm saying this
this week what is the most common bit of
advice you find yourself giving to
entrepreneurs that want to scale
okay so I I'm going to give two answers
real quick though first one plan to move
away from 360s because damn that's hard
you're taking a hard trip there so plan
yourself out of that 360 trap would be
the first thing the second thing is
something referring back to what you
said oh no actually three things there
the second thing is somebody you said
earlier is make the most of what you
have
figure out what you have that you're not
using fully and make the most of that
and whether that's a software tool a
piece of software that no one really
uses or whether it's a piece of
collateral that no one actually uses but
it's great or whether it's a technique
or a way of doing things that people
some people do and some people don't
positive deviation but figure out what
you've got already that you can just
make more of
and then the third and the thing I say
to everybody is doing sports analysis
get everybody in the business to do a
swap analysis find out where the heck
you're on air because you can't navigate
from where you want air to where you
want to be unless you know exactly where
you are and that's what analysis will
give you that grounding this is where we
are well okay let's plan our way forward
100 percent
thank you so much like I think real um
real privilege sort of picking your
brain on this kudos to you on yeah like
just yeah guy you've been on a real
journey you know um obviously found
yourself in difficult moments but I can
really tell that you're enjoying what
you're doing you're there's there's a
lot that you want to share and I think
that's really coming from an authentic
place that you want to share the
knowledge share the challenges and
mistakes that you've made so other
people don't have to make them or it's
not as painful uh for them so we're um
look I know you're super active on
LinkedIn if you're listening to this
right now and you're not connected with
Mike absolutely connect with him but
like when it comes to the the things
that we're talking about I know these
are the things that you talk about on a
daily weekly basis so let's just end on
like if someone is listening right now
they're recruiting entrepreneur like
what's the best way to connect with you
and talk about some of these systems and
your pillars and things to do is
critical LinkedIn as you say and we run
free workshops 90 minute workshops that
explain the Seven Pillars together great
level of depth we do probably four or
five a year they're free they're online
you register you get a video afterwards
and ebook and everything that goes with
it that's the first stage because you're
either going to see that and think yeah
hey that is for me and then we've got
plenty of ways that we can help you
we've got three different layers of
service if you will the thing that comes
after that if you want to go to the next
level some people do some people don't
it's a one day master class which we
have one next Wednesday it's full I know
this isn't a timing thing this is a
podcast but
um they fill up very quickly but that's
the whole day spent on the Seven Pillars
so if you like the workshop you're gonna
like the master class that's for damn
sure but I think you just ease yourself
in gently with us pick up our free
content we've got loads of it tune into
the my game show on the Thursday at 12
30.
get the stuff that we give in the The
Vault that we have all this free content
take from us and see whether
you know what we talk about is do you
share our beliefs and values I suppose
love it Mike thank you so much
thank you so much for listening to the
episode I hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode